bertrand est ce qu'on peut avoir des
nouvelles claire nette précise est
vraiment avec une hotte est
vraiment qu'il atteint jour la vôtre de
la reine elizabeth rêvait d'être
chroniqueur royal je présente des
bulletins de santé moi donc ce que l'on
peut dire hier en effet deux
visioconférences ont été annulés m au
dernier moment à la main des
visioconférences oui donc elle devait
recevoir
différents représentants de l'église je
pense par visioconférence et ça ça a été
annulé ce qui voudrait donc dire que je
ne suis pas médecin mais
vraisemblablement qu'elle est obligée de
garder le lit d'être alité à shalit et
voilà il semblerait que c'est ce qu'est
la presse en tout cas que nous nos
nièces entendre ne pourrait pas elle est
obligée niort de rester alité le château
de versailles château
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
plus vieux et le plus vaste château du
monde encore habité sac en 2000 mètres
carrés et on sait que sa chambre et dans
la tour est au troisième étage est ce
que la règle et des abbesses non parce
que tout le monde pourrait l'annuler
beaucoup de choses est-ce que les féras
[Rires]
la ferveur je ne comprends rien
la question est claire la reine
elizabeth et elle sera
[Rires]
longue et fatigué c'est bien là ce n est
pas bien
fatigué épuisé fatigué fatigué à la 4 l
et sera là
[Applaudissements]
doc se semblait en mesure de vous dire
que la reine elizabeth et
est-ce que son état de santé s'améliore
là on espère que son état de santé
s'améliore maintenant voilà aucun
communiqué n'a été fait de la part de
buckingham palace on connaît la devise
never explain never comes plein on ne
s'explique pas on ne se plaint pas sa
mère évidemment là ça n'a jamais autant
été d'actualité mais ce que l'on peut
peut-être dire toute petite parenthèse à
nouveau ils viennent d'eux nous ne nous
apprendre qu'ils ont ouvert un concours
slahi hier pour gagner 100 places pour
venir voir toutes ces stars les plus
grandes stars vont se produire au mois
de juin que le jubilé le jubilé
d'elizabeth ii en juin donc les façons
de dix ans de règne donc il semblerait
quand même que cette organisation est
quand même en contact avec fait les
trois médecins qui sont je vais
d'elizabeth ii au château écossais moi
je vois ça un peu comme un signe
rassurant lizarazu
lizarazu au jubilé n'y a pas d'accord
donc à présent vous non plus
ah ouais ces dessins stars non mais donc
on a dit ce qu'on y travaille est-ce
qu'on est plutôt inquiet ou plutôt ça
s'améliore parce que là ça fait quand
même pas mal de temps normalement là on
devrait avoir des nouvelles ou la reine
où la vue qui malgré leurs airs c'est
vraiment génial
ou la reine et ça va
vous avez vous gêne vous inviterai
michel cymes et michel cymes vous dira
comme quand on apprit bientôt 96 ans
qu'on chope le coronavirus
statistiquement quand même c'est grave
c'est gravissime dans mes donc elle elle
va mieux lopin ça fait longtemps qu'elle
a le groupe parce que c'est plus ça
traîne plus ça nous inquiète ben oui on
non la presse anglaise est très inquiète
en effet même si pour l'instant il parle
beaucoup de la rue cyr oui il ya une
vraie inquiétude à avoir oui oui nous on
est inquiet oui d'accord mais c'était
pas pour les dix bals que je peux rester
pour la reine
[Rires]
vous dites qu'elle prouve allait mieux
ma sont là pour qu'on ne la voit pas et
qu'on ne m'entend pasqualetti à l'oeil
mais souvent quand il met des journées
d'attenté envoyer des photos d'elle on
l'entendait y avait une photo d'elle en
train de moisir qui était sorti je viens
d'avoir un talent parce que pour moi
elle est alité elle garde le elle peut
mettre en avant les qualités me
semblerait que si tu elle peut pas
parler alors là je vous avoue que ces
informations là on n'est pas ce point
dans l'intimité c'est difficile de dire
radicalité mais oui et d'après les
informations qui me sont venues à l
égard de la chambre elle n'est même pas
dans les appartements elle et fred ont
rédigé la
chaudronnée des révélations le 7 au soir
on a des clients qui attendent
non mais ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que le coc vinyle s'aggrave à
partir d'une neuvième jour entre le 9e
et le 12e jour alors est ce qu'ils
attendent pas la peine qu'on a ici la
personne qu'on appelle à l'aide
c'est quelqu'un qui peut prédire les
rastas voilà merci jean marc
adamus et la normale le coc vie de 50
toujours un tour le 9e et le deuxième
jour alors qu'il restait 10 atteint 2
passes délai pour donner des nouvelles
de la reine au cas où l'état s'aggrave à
partir du 12e jour par exemple on doit
démissionner six jours donc ça serait
aussi peut-être une possibilité qu'ils
attendent avant de nous donner des
nouvelles l'angleterre toute entière
attend en tout cas eu le monde et le
monde entier on voit bien le
raz-de-marée les messages qui arrivent
du mien n'a même eu des ratés chez de
lanmeur en
tout cas ce que l'on peut dire aussi
c'est que la presse anglaise nous
apprend quand même qu'il ya des choses
qui commencent à bouger le times ce nous
révéler par exemple quel à onze jours de
couverture qui sont déjà prêtes donc ça
vaudrait donc voyez
peut-être déjà naturel d'orson vient
perturber tabac je croyais et je crois
qu'à des jetons
je me pose la question des moyens navals
et totalitaire je croyais été comme ça
sur le livre comme ça c'est une
couverture son royaume chine oui
certains anglais commencent à dire que
derrière les symptômes légers et duco
vides il y aurait quelque chose de plus
grave qu'on nous cacherait est-ce que ça
c'est possible qu'en syrie sera d'abord
il
sera d'abord
des maladies plus graves en dessous leur
vie à nouveau je ne suis pas médecin
mais la presse dite sérieuse ne reprend
pas ce bruit dont vous fait tabloïd
allusions et là c'est uniquement les
tables vides qui pour le coup de
l'entraînement vendre du papier non mais
il ya quand même deux choses
intéressantes la première c'est qu'on
parlait d'une première petite mort quand
son mari est mort c'est très très dur
pour elle effectivement on voit c'était
cette image aux dames existe tout seul
et puis à nous tous que c'est important
la réalité 96 en réalité c'est jamais
bon et puis à un moment donné ou chez
les personnages et ses camps dans leur
tête elle lâche jamais
pourrais je vous dis
bertrand elle attendra elle habitera le
chemin des côtes et une commode la reine
d'angleterre
ah ouais allez on se croise tous les
toits pour que le jury et le public en
mode puisse puisse avoir lu vous
imaginez c'est historique pour le coup
et je rappelle à nouveau mode à des
millions de livres qui ont été engagées
mais anglais attendre vraiment le jubilé
est ce que c'est le mouret avant le gym
il y aurait quand même lieu bien sûr
banon la non l'effet ch'ti pour le
menacer de se faire sur des puddings moi
j'ai eu plein de chroniques
concert géant sur le tas de buckingham
alors qu'on l'enterré donc non mais
c'est sûr qu'on a un anniversaire c'est
sûr qu'au n'y a pas de jubiler mais si
la reine venait à mourir il y aura pas
de pile à l'heure actuelle le jubilé est
maintenue puisque je viens de vous dire
que sa ville a fait naître
ces packs prochaine
étape est une otite traire le prochain à
lille et nautiques sur la tête de ma
mère
c'est une enceinte
oui mais est ce qu'on nous dit on
pourrait nous mentir par exemple les
deux visioconférences qui ont été
annulés est ce qu elles ont été prévues
longtemps avant avant le colis de
comment ça se passe c'est normal
l'agenda de la reine est prévu que
certaines activités sont prévues deux
ans à la folle alors là par rapport à
ces deux visioconférences jeu super g de
pouvoir vous dire exactement depuis
combien de jours elle n'était pas en
tout cas l étoile a détruit le boulet
vue jusqu'en 2024 oui oui oui deux
en-avant sur mener à bien ce que je
crois que je dois faire un point bas et
qu'elle
fait ou si c'est toujours incroyable
quand la reine arrive quelque part ça
fait deux ans que les gens l'attendent à
servel absolument lavaret monter monter
la pression comme pernikoff dans tpm
[Rires]
est
ce que le média américain qui a annoncé
sa mort et quelques jours a démenti
l'information et les regrets sur le
match a été démentie avec ce qu'ils ont
dit escalettes a informé de croire
qu'elle a été informée que ce média
d'amoureux que ce média
est celui dont il veut dire ce que j'ai
lu mais également dans la presse alors
voilà il semblerait que les liens peu
ceux des télévisions dans sa chambre un
quai chauffer uniquement par une grande
cheminée comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure et il s'est renseigné
viseur et
regarder les informations continuent
c'est une info et on aimerait pour
l'instant du moins lui cacher le
comprirent à l'uqar accord de télévision
abc la chambre qui chauffe mais non
aussi je crois qu'il chauffe et la
télévision télévision à gaz
la chair est chaud mais
c'est pas moi pas de trois plus jeunes
sera gardée d'un thème c'est la bordel
mais c'est bon et mouvements de membres
de la famille qui peuvent donner des
indices est ce qu'il ya des parts et 10
avec le prince édouard et est rentré à
sa
droite un drame on est très malade oui
si on a des symptômes légers d'ukraine
qui tombe et c'est très difficile parce
que charles et camilla sont out il ya
plus d'activités officielles ce
qu'ils ont encore de ce fait le coup de
la faire obstacle donc on est vraiment
une famille royale qui est resserrée au
minium et hommes william et kate n'avait
pas grand chose de privé on est en
vacances aussi dans l'art agenda donc
non ça sera l'émission de pistes et de
se péter la gueule château ariza pour
harry vient revoilà c'est quelque chose
que l'on regarde on regarde s'il venait
à prendre un vol ça nous indique en
effet qu'il y aurait urgence rouge au
sein duquel ils à leur folie arrive on
pense à ris
maintenant reviendra c'est une autre qui
est pas moins quelques jours il a dû à
la barre avait demandé à sa petite fille
une de ses petites filles qui mérite le
génie de se rendre elle sert en dieu dix
jours auprès auprès du prince harry et
de mégane et la presse nous dit que
c'était simplement pour s'assurer de
leur présence lors du jubilé vous voyez
les choses ne sont pas si patents faut
que ça